Biden came out as a really sleepy sweet
Grandpa yeah went to scr Scranton I grow
up in Scranton
Pennsylvania my dad my dad lost his
job no joke I'm not kidding around
here no no human being in the world
thinks that's a joke then he would do
the number thing number one the one part
number two what the guy said number
three you know the drill come
on no we don't now what he does is he
kind of Whispers and then he yells he's
like we know how to get natural gas cuz
we can't get it we know how to get it
that's what we do we get the people that
P one public the private Pirates of the
Caribbean wow Dana carvey's impression
the initial impression he did was what
he says was the initial oratorical
rhetorical strategy of of Joe Biden and
it has changed over time and it has
gotten angrier and it has the the
crescendos have become more sudden